and a historic overnight meeting North
and South Korea agreed to work toward
denuclearizing the Korean Peninsula and
formally ending the Korean War North
Korean leader Kim jong-un and South
Korean president moon jae-in raised
their arms in a show of unity look at
that they promised to pursue peace but
left many of the details for later talks
the two men met and shook hands at the
border along Korea's Demilitarized Zone
in a moment filled with symbolism Kim
became the first North Korean leader to
set foot on South Korean soil Ben Tracy
is in the South Korean capital Seoul
been good morning good morning so this
summit turned out to be heavy on both
style and substance kim jeong-hoon is
saying that what he's agreed to is just
the tip of the iceberg and that he
actually plans to follow through on the
agreement this is a moment no one could
have predicted just a few months ago but
after signing their agreement Kim
jong-un and president moon jae-in were
clearly pleased with what they had
accomplished Hanoi the South Korean
president declared a new era of peace on
the Korean Peninsula the two Koreas
agreed to officially end the Korean War
by the end of the year resume reunions
of families separated during the
conflict and turned the DMZ into what
they call a genuine peace zone president
moon will visit North Korea for a second
summit this fall the two leaders seemed
to have an instant rapport the minute
Kim Jong moon made history by becoming
the first North Korean leader to step
foot in the south in a brief diplomatic
dance he invited president moved across
the military demarcation line back into
the north
[Music]
South Korea literally rolled out the red
carpet for their once recent enemy and
the two men were often seen smiling and
even laughing together after planting a
pine tree a symbol of peace they sat
alone for a full 30 minutes and what
appeared to be an in-depth conversation
but North Korea agreed to the
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
was the ultimate goal of this summit so
far there are no specifics as to how or
when that will happen or what Kim Jong
moon wants in return the Devils is in
the details in BOM Chong is a retired
lieutenant general of the South Korean
army
he's been surprised by Kim Jong Un's
pivot towards peace are you buying what
he's selling I'm going to give him the
benefit of that doubt with a certain
dose of caution so I'm gonna wait and
see and I don't think I'm gonna have to
wait too long now we should mention that
North Korea has promised to denuclearize
in the past and not actually done that
but Kim Jong moon does seem at least
committed to no longer launching
missiles he even joked that he's no
longer going to interrupt president
moons sleep with those early morning
rocket launches Gayle right so he's got
jokes - all right Ben Tracy and Seoul
thank you very much